development so on the impeachment
inquiry public hearings are set to begin
next week
president Trump said yesterday they
should not be made public as newly
released transcripts continue to offer
more details a president of the
president's alleged dealings with
Ukraine and now there are hints that mr.
Trump's former national security adviser
may also testify against him we - Jiang
is at the White House this morning we
gyah good morning good morning Michelle
and good morning to everybody President
Trump says the only thing that matters
is the summary of his call with
Ukraine's leader and now he is
considering releasing a transcript of
their first call and you are so right we
have learned through court filings that
former national security adviser John
Bolton could be dropping new bombshells
about all the stuff that was happening
behind the scenes in Atlanta Friday
President Trump addressed a crowd
chanting blacks for Trump trying to drum
up support for his re-election bid the
Democrats have taken african-american
voters totally for granted earlier at
the White House the president brushed
off the vivid picture unfolding in the
impeachment inquiry painted by several
witnesses who described a quid pro quo
with Ukraine I'm not concerned about
anything the testimony has all been fine
I mean for the most part I never even
heard of these people they include the
former White House senior Russia
director Fiona Hill who said during a
July meeting US ambassador to the EU
Gordon song Lindh was talking about how
he had an agreement with chief of staff
Mulvaney for a presidential meeting with
the Ukrainians if they were going to go
forward with investigations into the
Biden family White House Ukraine
director Alex VIN moon was at the
meeting and testified the same thing
that the Ukrainians would have to
deliver an investigation into the
Biden's
it was explicit there was no ambiguity
and that this had been coordinated with
chief of staff Mulvaney last month
Mulvaney denied that what was on the
table for a precondition and was the
investigation of buries m'a ever brought
up as a condition to meet with President
Trump no not to me and not anybody I
know of
but he'll testified former national
security adviser John Bolton was so
alarmed by the meeting that he told her
to go straight to a top White House
lawyer tell Eisenberg that I am not part
of whatever drug deal song wind and
Mulvaney are cooking up on this in a
court filing Friday lawyer suggested
Bolton has more he can share with
Congress if a federal judge clears the
way for him to testify Bolton they right
had many relevant meetings and
conversations that have not yet been
discussed in the testimonies so far a
mohini defined as a defied a subpoena to
appear on Capitol Hill yesterday
President Trump said he would quote love
for Mulvaney and others who know him to
testify but added that would lend
credibility to a corrupt investigation
the president says the whistleblower who
started it all should be revealed but in
a rare interview Dana Ivanka Trump said
the person's identity isn't particularly
relevant another wrinkle in all of this
we just thank you